-- is the next group of topics
in 6.033 call fault tolerance.
And the goal here is to learn
how to build reliable systems.
An extreme case, or at
least our ideal goal,
is to try to build systems
that will never fail.
And what will find is that
we really can't do that,
but what we'll try
to do is to build
systems which maybe fail less
often than if you built them
without the principles that
we're going to talk about.
So the idea is how to
build reliable systems.
So in order to understand how
to build reliable systems,
we need to understand what
makes systems unreliable.
And that has to do with
understanding what faults are.
What problems occur in systems
that cause systems to fail?
And you've actually seen many
examples of faults already.
Informally, a fault
is just some kind
of a flaw or a mistake that
causes a component or a module
not to perform the way
it's supposed to perform.
And we'll formalize
this notion a little bit
today as we go along.
So there are many examples
of faults, several of which
you've already seen.
A system could fail
because it has a software
fault, a bug in a piece of
software, so when you run it,
it doesn't work according
to the way you expect.
And that causes
something bad to happen.
You might have hardware faults.
You store some data on a disk.
You go back and read it.
And it isn't there.
But it's been corrupted.
And that's an example
of a fault that
might cause bad things
to happen if you
build a system that relies on a
disk storing data persistently.
You might have design faults
where a design fault might
be something where
you try to, let's say,
figure out how much buffering
to put into a network switch.
And you put into
little buffering.
So what ends up happening is
too many packets get dropped.
So you might actually just
have some bad logic in there,
and that causes you to design
something that isn't quite
going to work out.
And you might, of course,
have implementation faults
where you have a design,
and then you implement it,
and you made a mistake
in how it's implemented.
And that could cause
faults as well.
And another example
of the kind of faults
is an operational fault
sometimes called a human error
where a user actually
does something
that you didn't anticipate
or was told not to do,
and that caused bad
things to happen.
For all of these
faults, there are really
two categories of
faults regardless
of what kind of fault it is.
The first category of
faults are latent faults.
So an example of
a latent fault is,
let's say you have a
bug in a program where
instead of testing
if A less than B,
you test if A greater than B.
So that's a bug in a program.
But until it actually runs,
until that line of code runs,
this fault in the
program isn't actually
going to do anything bad.
It isn't going to have
any adverse effect.
And therefore, this fault is
an example of a latent fault.
And nothing is happening
until it gets triggered.
And when it gets triggered,
that latent fault
might become an active fault.
Now, the problem when a latent
fault becomes an active fault
is that when you run
that line of code,
you might have a mistake
coming out at the output,
which we're going
to call an error.
So when an active
fault is exercised,
it leads to an error.
And the problem with errors
is that if you're not
careful about how
you deal with errors,
and most of what we're
going to talk about
is how to deal with
errors, if you're not
careful about how you deal with
errors that leads to a failure.
So somewhat more
formally, a fault
is just any flaw in an
underlying component
or underlying subsystem
that your system is using.
Now, if the fault turns out
not to be exercised then.
There's no error.
There's no error that
results, and there's
no failure that results.
It's only when you
have an active fault
that you might have an error.
And when you have an error,
you might have a failure.
And what we're
going to try to do
is to understand how to
deal with these errors
so that when errors
occur we're going
to try to hide them or
mask them, or do something
such that these errors don't
propagate and cause failures.
So the general goal,
as I mentioned before,
is to build systems
that don't fail.
So, in order to build
systems that don't fail,
there are two approaches
at a 50,000 foot level.
One approach to build a
system that doesn't fail
is to build it
out of, make sure,
every system is
going to be built out
of components or modules.
And those modules are
going to be built out
of modules themselves.
One approach might be to
make sure that no module ever
fails, that no component that
you use to build your bigger
system ever fails.
And it'll turn out that for
reasons that will become clear
based on an understanding
of the techniques
we are going to employ to
build systems that don't fail,
it'll turn out that this
is extremely expensive.
It's just not going to work
out for us to make sure
that our disks never
fail, and memory never
fails, and our networks
never fail, and so on.
It's just too expensive
and nearly impossible.
So what we're going
to do actually
is to start with
unreliable components.
And we're going to build
reliable systems out
of unreliable components
or modules more generally.
And what this means is that
the system that you build
had better be tolerant of
faults that these underlying
components have, which is
why the design of systems
that don't fail or rarely
fail is essentially
the same as designing systems
that are tolerant of faults,
hence fault tolerance.
So that's the reason why we
care about fault tolerance.
So let's take the
example of the kinds
of, just to crystallize these
notions of faults and failures
a little bit more.
So let's say you have a big
system that has a module.
Let's call it M1.
And this module uses a couple
of other modules, M2 and M3.
And let's say M2 uses
another module, M4,
where users might
be an invocation.
Or imagine this is an
RPC call, for example.
And, let's say that M4 in here
has some component inside M4
like a disk or something,
some piece of software in M4.
And, let's say that that fails.
So, it has a fault.
It gets triggered.
It becomes active,
leads to an error.
It actually fails,
that little component.
So when this fault becomes a
failure, a couple of things
could happen.
M4, which is the module to which
this little failure belongs,
can do one of two things.
One possibility
is that this fault
that caused the failure
gets exposed to the caller.
So, M4 hasn't
managed to figure out
a way to hide this failure
from M2, which means
that the fault propagates up.
The failure gets visible, and
the fault propagates up to M2.
And now, M2 actually sees the
underlying component's failure.
So the point here is that
this little component fault
caused a failure
here which caused
M4 itself to fail because M4 now
couldn't hide this underlying
failure, and reported
something that
was a failure, that
was an output that
didn't conform to the
specification of M4 out to M2.
Now, as far as M2 is concerned,
all that has happened so far
is that the failure
of this module, M4,
has shown up as a
fault to M2, right,
because an underlying
module has failed.
It doesn't mean
that M2 has failed.
It just means that M2
has now seen a fault.
And M2 now might manage
to hide this fault, which
would mean that M1 doesn't
actually see anything.
It doesn't see the
underlying fault
that caused the failure at all.
But of course, if M2
now couldn't hide this
or couldn't mask
this failure, then it
would propagate an
erroneous output out
to M1, an output
that didn't conform
to the specification
of M2, leading M1
to observe this as
a fault, and so on.
So, the general idea is
that failures of sub-modules
tend to show up as faults
in the higher level module.
And our goal is to
try to somehow design
these systems that use lots
of modules and components
where at some level
in the end we would
like to avoid failing overall.
But inside here, we won't
be able to go about making
everything failure-free.
I mean, there might be
failures inside sub-modules.
But the idea is to
ensure, or try to ensure,
that M1 itself, the highest
level system, doesn't fail.
So let's start with
a few examples.
In fact, these all examples of
things that we've already seen.
And even though we haven't
discussed it as such,
we've seen a lot of examples
of fault tolerance in the class
so far.
So, for example, if you have
bad synchronization code
like you didn't use the
locking discipline properly
or didn't use any of the other
synchronization primitives
properly, you might have a
software fault that leads
to the failure of a module.
Another example that we saw
when we talk about networking
is when we talk about routing
where the idea in here
was that we talked about
rat in protocols that
could handle failures of links.
So, certain links could fail,
leading to certain paths
to not be usable.
But, the routing system
managed to find other paths
around the network.
And that was because
there were other parts
available because
the network itself
was built with some degree
of redundancy underneath.
And the routing protocol
was able to exploit that.
Another example that we
saw again from networks
is packet loss.
We had best effort networks
that would lose packets.
And it didn't mean that
your actual transfer
of a file at the ends and
where would miss data.
We came up with
retransmissions as a mechanism
to use, again, another
form of redundancy
where you try the same thing
again to get your data through.
Another example of the failure
that we saw was congestion
collapse --
-- where there was too much data
being sent out into the network
too fast, and the
network would collapse.
And our solution to
this problem was really
to shed load was to run the
system slower than it otherwise
would, by having
the people sending
data send data slower in order
to alleviate this problem.
Another example which
we saw last time was,
or briefly saw last time was
the domain name system where
the domain name
servers are replicated.
So, if you couldn't reach one
to resolve your domain name,
you could go to another one.
And all of these,
or most of these
actually use the same techniques
that we're going to talk about.
And all of these
techniques are built
around some form of redundancy
on another except probably
the locking thing.
But all of the others are built
around some form of redundancy.
And we'll understand this
more systematically today
and in the next
couple of classes.
So our goal here is to develop
a systematic approach --
-- to building systems
that are fault tolerant.
And the general approach for
all fault tolerant systems
is to use three techniques.
So the first one we've
already seen, which is
don't build a monolithic system.
Always build it around modules.
And the reason is
that it will that
be easier for us to isolate
these modules firstly
one from another.
But then, when
modules fail, it will
be easier for us to treat
those failures as faults,
and then try to
hide those faults,
and apply the same
technique, which brings us
to the second step, which is
when failures occur causing
errors, we need a plan
for the higher level
module to detect errors.
So failure results in an error.
We have to know
that it's happened,
which means we need
techniques to detect it.
And, of course, once
we detect an error
we have a bunch of things
we could do with it.
But ideally, if
you want to prevent
the failure of that system, of
a system that's observed errors,
you need a way to
hide these errors.
The jargon for this
is mask errors.
And if we do this, if we
build systems that do this,
then it's possible
for us to build
systems that can form to spec.
So the goal here is to try
to make sure that systems
conform to some specification.
And if things don't
conform to a specification,
then that's when we
call it a failure.
And sometimes we
play some tricks
where in order to build
systems that "never fail",
we'll scale back the
specification to actually allow
for things that would in
fact be considered failures,
but are things that still
would conform to the spec.
So we relax the
specification to make sure
that we could still meet the
notion of a failure free system
or a fault tolerant system.
And we'll see some
examples of that
actually in the next lecture.
And I've already mentioned,
the general trick
for all of these systems
that we're going to study,
examples that we're
going to study,
is to use some
form of redundance.
And that's the way in which
we're going to mask errors.
And almost all systems,
or every system
that I know of
that's fault tolerant
uses redundancy in
some form or another.
And often it's not
obvious how it uses it.
But it does actually
use redundancy.
So I'm going to now give an
example that will turn out
to be the same example we'll
use for the next three or four
lectures.
And so, you may as well,
you should probably
get familiar with this
example because we're
going to see this
over and over again.
It's a really simple example,
but it's complicated enough
that everything we want to
learn about fault tolerance
will be visible in this example.
So it starts with
the person who wants
to do a bank transaction at an
ATM, or a PC, or on a computer.
You want to do a
bank transaction.
And the way this works, as
you probably know, is it
goes over some
kind of a network.
And then, if you want to
do this bank transaction,,
it goes to a server,
which is run by your bank.
And the way this
normally works is
that the server
has a module that
uses a database system,
which deals with managing
your account information.
And because you
don't want to forget,
and the bank shouldn't forget
how much money you have,
there is data that's
stored on disk.
And we're going to be
doing things that are
actions of the following form.
We're going to be
asking the transfer
from some account to another
account some amount of money.
And now, of course, anything
could fail in between.
So, for example, there could
be a problem in the network.
And the network could fail.
Or the software running
on the server could fail.
this database system
could crash or report
bad values or something.
The disc could fail.
And do we want systematic
techniques by which this
transfer here or
all of these calls
that look a lot like
transfer do the right thing?
And so, this doing
the right thing
is an informal way of
saying meet a specification.
So, we first have to decide what
we want for a specification.
That has to hold true
no matter what happens,
no matter what failures occur.
So one example of
a specification
might be to say, no matter
what happens, if I invoke this
and it returns, then
this amount of money
has to be transferred
from here to here.
So that could be a specification
that you might expect.
It also turns out this
specification is extremely hard
to meet.
And we're not even
going to try to do it.
And this is the weasel
wording I said before about,
we'll modify the specification.
So, we'll change the
specification going forward
for this example to mean,
if this call returns,
then no matter what
failures occur,
either a transfer has
happened exactly once,
or the state of the system is as
if the transfer didn't even get
started, OK, which
is reasonable.
I mean, and then if you really
care about moving the money,
and you are determined
that it hasn't been moved,
you or some program
might try it again,
which actually is another
form of using redundancy where
you just try it over again.
And we won't
understand completely
why a specification that says
you have to do this exactly
once if it returns, why
that's hard to implement,
why that's hard to
achieve, we'll see that
in the next couple of classes.
So, for now, just realized
that the specification here
is it should happen
exactly once or it should
be as if no partial
action corresponding
to the [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
of this transfer happened.
So the state of the system
must be as if the system never
saw this transfer request.
So any module could failure.
So, let's take some
examples of failures
in order to get some
terminology that'll
help us understand faults.
So one thing that could
happen is that you
could have a disk failure.
So the disc could just fail.
And one example of a disk
failure is the disk fails
and then it just stops working.
And it tells the
database system that's
trying to read and write data
from it that it isn't working.
So if that kind of failure
happens where this module here
with this component
just completely
stops and tells the higher-level
module that it stopped,
that's an example of a failure.
That's called a
fail stop failure.
And more generally,
any module that
tells the higher-level
module that it just
stops working without reporting
anything else, no outputs,
that's fail stop.
Of course, you could have disks.
And you might have failures
that aren't fail stop.
You might have
something where there
is some kind of error
checking associated
with every sector on your disk.
And, disk might start
reporting errors that
say that this is a bad sector.
So, it doesn't fail stop, but
it tells the higher level,
the database system in this
case that some data that's read,
or some data that's
been written,
there's a bad
sector, which means
that the checksum doesn't match
the data that's being read.
When you have an
error like that where
it doesn't stop working
but it tells you
that something bad is going on,
that's an example of a failure.
That's called a
fail fast failure.
I actually don't think these
terms, that most of these terms
are particularly important.
Fail stop is usually
important and worth knowing,
but the reason to go
through these terms
is more to understand that there
are various kinds of failures
possible.
So in one case it stops working.
In another case,
it just tells you
that it's not working
but continues working.
It tells you that
certain operations
haven't been correctly done.
Now, another thing that could
happen when, for example,
the disc has fail
stop, has fail fast
is that the database
system might decide
that right operations, you're
not allowed to write things
to disk because the disk is
either fail completely or is
fail fast.
But it might allow actions or
requests that are read only.
So, for example, it
might allow users
to come up to an ATM
machine, and just
read how much money they
have from their account
because it might be that there
is a cache of the data that's
in memory in the database.
So it might allow read-only
actions, in which case
the system's perform
is functioning
with only a subset
of the actions
that it's supposed to be taking.
And if that happens,
that kind of failure
is called a fail soft failure,
where not all of the interfaces
are available, but a
subset of the interfaces
are available and
correctly working.
And the last kind of
failure that could happen
is that in this
example, let's say
that failures are
occurring when there's
a large number of people trying
to make these requests at ATMs.
And, there is some
problems that have arisen.
And somebody determines
that the problem
arises when there
is too many people
gaining access to the
system at the same time.
And the system might
now move to a mold
where it allows only a small
number of actions at a time,
a small number of concurrent
actions at a time,
or maybe one action at a time.
So, one user can come at a
time to the system, which
means the systems, there
has been a failure,
but the way the system's dealing
with it is that it determines
that the failure doesn't get
triggered when the load is low.
So it might function
at low performance.
It still provides all
of the interfaces,
but just at very low performance
or at lower performance.
And that kind of behavior
is called failsafe.
So it's moved to a mode
where it's just scaled back
how much work it's
willing to do,
and does it at
degraded performance.
OK, so the plan now is
for the rest of today,
so tomorrow from
the next lecture on,
what we're going to do
is understand algorithms
for how we go about and how
you build systems that actually
do one or all of these in
order to meet the specification
that we want.
But before we do that you have
to understand a little bit
about models for faults.
In order to build
fault tolerant systems,
it's usually a good
idea to understand
a little bit more
quantitatively models or faults
that occur in systems.
And primarily,
this discussion is
going to be focused
on hardware faults
because most people don't
understand how software
faults are to be modeled.
But since all our
systems are going
to be built on hardware,
for example discs
are going to be
really, really common.
Our network links are
going to be common.
And all of those conform
nicely to models.
It's worth understanding
how that works.
So, for example, a
disk manufacturer
might report that the error rate
of undetected errors, so disks
usually have a fair amount
of error detection in them.
But, they might report that the
error rate of undetected errors
is, say, ten to the minus
12 or ten to the minus 13.
And that number
looks really small.
That says that out
of that many bits,
maybe one bit is corrupted,
and you can't detect it.
But, you have to
realize that given
modern workloads, for example
take Google as an example
that you saw from
last recitation,
the amount of data that's being
stored in the system like that
or in the world in general is
so huge that a ten to the minus
13th error rate means
that you're probably
seeing some bad data and
file that you can never fix
or never detect
every couple of days.
Network people would
tell you that fiber optic
links have an error rate of
one error in ten to the 12th.
But you have to realize
that these links are sending
so many gigabits per second
that one error in ten
to the 12th means
something like there's
an error that you can't detect
maybe every couple of hours.
What that really means is
that at the higher layers,
you need to do
more work in order
to make sure that your data
is protected because you can't
actually rely on the fact that
your underlying components have
these amazingly low numbers
because there's so much data
going on, being sent or
being stored on these systems
that you need to have other
techniques at a higher layer
to protect, if you really
care about the integrity
of your data.
In addition to
these raw numbers,
there's two or
three other metrics
that people use to understand
faults and failures.
The first one is the number
of tolerated failures.
So, for example, if you
build a system to store data
and you're worried about discs
failing or discs reporting
at [earnest?] values, you might
replicate that data across
many, many discs.
And then when you
design your system,
one of the things you would
want to analyze and report
is the number of tolerated
failures of discs.
So, for example, if you build
a system out of seven discs,
you might say that you can
handle up to two failed disks,
or simply like that,
depending on how
you've designed your system.
And that's usually a good thing
to report because then people
who use your system can
know how to provision
or engineer your system.
The second metric
which we're going
to spend a few more minutes
on is something called
the mean time to failure.
And what this says is
it takes a model where
you have a system that
starts at time zero,
and it's running fine.
And then at some point
in time, it fails.
And then, when it
fails, that error
is made known to an operator.
Or it's made known
to some higher
level that has a plan
to work around it
to repair this failure.
And then, once the
failure gets repaired,
it takes some time for the
failure to get repaired.
And once it's repaired
it starts running again.
And then it fails at some
other point in the future.
And when it goes through the
cycle of failures and repairs,
you end up with a timeline
that looks like this.
So you might start at time zero.
And the system is working fine.
And then there is a
failure that happens here.
And then the system is down
for a certain period of time.
And then somebody
repairs the system,
and then it continues to work.
And then it fails
again, and so on.
And so, for each of
the durations of time
that the system
is working, let's
assume it's starting
at zero, each of these
defines a period of
time that I'm going
to call TTF or time to fail.
OK, so this is the first
time to fail interval.
This is the second time to
fail This is the second time
to fail interval,
time to repair,
and this is the third time
to fail interval, and so on.
And analogously
in between here, I
could define these time
to repair intervals,
TTR1, TTR2, and so on.
So, the mean time to failure is
just the mean of these values.
There's some duration of time.
You're like, three
hours the system
worked, and then it crashed.
That's TTF1.
And then, somebody to repair
it worked now for six hours.
That's TTF2, and so on.
If you run your system for
a long enough period of time
like a disk or anything
else, and then you
observe all these time
to fail samples, and take
the mean of that, that tells
you a mean time to failure.
The reason this
is interesting is
that you could run your system
for a really long period
of time, and build up a
metric called availability.
So, for example, if
you're running a website,
and the way this
website works is it
runs for a while and then every
once in awhile it crashes.
So its network crashes and
people can't get to you.
So you could run this for
months or years on end,
and then observe these values.
You could run this every month.
You could decide what
availability is, and decide
if it's good enough
or if you want
to make it higher or lower.
So you could now define
your availability
to be the fraction of time that
your system is up and running.
And the fraction of time that
the system is up and running
is the fraction of
time on this timeline
that you have this
kind of shaded thing.
OK, so that's just equal
to the sum of all the time
to failure numbers
divided by the total time.
And the total time is
just the sum of all
the TTF's and the TTR's.
OK, and that's what availability
means is the fraction of time
that your system
is available is up.
Now, if you divide both the
top and the bottom by N,
this number works out to
be the mean time to failure
divided by the mean time to
failure plus the mean time
to repair.
So this is a useful notion
because now it tells you that
you can [point?] your system
for a very long period of time,
and build up a mean estimate,
mean values of the time
to failure and the
time to repair,
and just come up with the
notion of what the availability
of the system is.
And then, decide based on
whether it's high enough or not
whether you want to improve
some aspect of the system
and whether it's worth doing.
So it turns out this
mean time to failure,
and therefore availability
is related for components
to a notion called
the failure rate.
So let me define
So the failure rate
is defined, it's
also called a hazard function.
That's what people use the
term H of T, the hazard rate.
That's defined as
the probability
that you have a failure of a
system or a component in time,
T to T plus delta T,
given that it's working,
we'll say, OK, at time T, OK?
So it's a conditional
probability.
It's the probability that
you'll fail in the next time
instant given that it's
correctly working and has
been correctly working.
It's correctly
working at time T.
So, if you look at
this for a disk,
most discs look like the
picture shown up here.
This is also called
the bathtub curve
because it looks like a bathtub.
What you see at the left
end here are new discs.
So, the X axis here shows time.
I guess it's a
little shifted below.
You can't read some stuff
that's written at the bottom.
But the X axis shows
time, and the Y axis
shows the failure rate.
So, when you take a new
component like a new light bulb
or a new disc or anything new,
there is a pretty high chance
that it'll actually fail because
manufacturers, when they sell
you stuff, don't
actually sell you things
without actually
burning them in first.
So for semiconductors,
that's also called yield.
They make a whole
number of chips,
and then they're
burning a few, and then
they only give you the rest.
And the stuff that's...
survive the burn in
and the fraction that
survives the burning
is also called the yield.
So what you see on our left,
the colorful term for that
is infant mortality.
So it's things that die when
they are really, really young.
And then, once you get
past the early mortality,
you end up with a flat failure,
a conditional probability
for failure.
And what this says
is that, and I'll
get to this and a little bit.
But what this says is that once
you are in the flat region,
it says that the
probability of failure
is essentially independent of
what's happened in the past.
And then you stay
here for a while.
And then if the system
has been operating
like a disk has been
operating for awhile,
let's say three years or five
years typically for discs,
then the probability
of failure starts
going up again because that's
usually due to wear and tear,
which for hardware components
is certainly the case.
There are a couple
of interesting things
about this curve that you
should realize, particularly
when you read specifications
for things like discs.
Disc manufacturers
will report a number,
like the mean time
to failure number.
And the mean time
to failure number
that the report
might usually, I mean
for discs might be 200,000
hours or 300,000 hours.
I mean, that's a really
long period of time.
That's 30 years.
So when you look at
a number like that,
you have to ask
whether what it means
is that discs really
survive 30 years.
And anybody who
is on the computer
knows, you know, most discs
don't survive 30 years.
So they are actually
reporting one
over the reciprocal of this
thing at the flat region
of the curve because this
conditional failure probability
rate, at this operation
time when the only reason
things fail is completely
random failures
not related to wear and tear.
So when disc manufacturers
report a mean time
to failure number, they are
actually reporting something
that that's the time that
you're disc is likely to work.
What that number really says is
that during the period of time
that the disc is
normally working,
the probability of
a random failure
is one over the mean
time to failure.
That's what it really says.
So the other number that
they also report, often
in smaller print, is it the
expected operational lifetime.
And that's usually something
like three years or four years
or five years, whatever
it is they report.
And that's where this
thing starts going up,
and beyond a point where
the probability of failures
above some threshold,
they report
that as the expected
operational lifetime.
Now, for software, this
curve doesn't actually apply,
or at least nobody really knows
what the curve is for software.
What is true for software,
though, is infant mortality,
things were the conditional
probability of failure
is high for new software, which
is why you are sort of well
advised, the moment the
new upgrade of something
comes around, most
people who are prudent
wait a little bit to just make
sure all the bugs are out,
and things get a
little bit stable.
So they wait a few months.
You are always a couple
of revisions behind.
So I do believe that for
software, the left side
of the curve holds.
It's totally unclear that
there is a flat region,
and it's totally
unclear that things
start rising again with age.
So the reason for
this curve, being
the way it is, is a lot of
this is based on the fact
that things are mechanical
and have wear and tear.
But the motivation
for this kind of curve
actually comes from demographics
and from human lifespans.
So this is a picture
that I got from,
it's a website
called mortality.org,
which is a research project
run by demographers.
And they have amazing data.
There's way more data available
but human life expectancy
and demographics than
anything about software.
What this shows here is
actually the same bathtub curve
as in the previous chart.
It just doesn't look
like that because the Y
axis is on a log scale.
So given that it's
rising linearly
between 0.001 and 0.01,
on a linear scale that
looks essentially flat.
So human beings for the
probability of death,
at a certain time,
given that
you are alive at a
certain time, that
follows this curve here,
essentially a bathtub curve.
At the left hand, of course,
there is infant mortality.
This I think I pulled the data down.
This is from an
article that appeared
where the data for the
US population 1999.
It starts off again
with infant mortality.
And then it's flat for a while.
Then it rises up.
Now, there's a lot
of controversy,
it turns out, for whether the
bathtub curve at the right end
holds for human beings or not.
And, some people
believe it does,
and some people
believe it doesn't.
But the point here is that
for human beings anyway,
the rule of thumb that insurance
companies use for determining
insurance premiums is
that the log of the death
rate, the log of the probability
of dying in a certain age
grows linearly with the time
that somebody has been alive.
And that's what
this graph shows,
that on large scale on
the Y axis, you have a line.
And that's what they use for
determining insurance premiums.
OK, so the reason this bathtub
curve is actually useful
is, so if you go back,
let's go back here.
The reason both these
numbers are useful,
the flat portion of
the bathtub curve
and the expected operational
lifetime is the following.
It's not like this flat
portion of the curve
where the disc manufacturer
reports the mean time
to failure.
That's 30 years.
It's not like
that's useless even
though you're disc only might
run for three to four years.
The reason is that if you
have a project, if you have
a system where you
are willing to upgrade
your disk every three
years where you've budgeted
for upgrading your discs
every said three years, then
you might be better off buying a
disk whose expected lifetime is
only five years but whose
flat portion is really low.
So in particular, if you're
given to discs, one of which
has a curve that
looks like that,
and another that has a curve
that looks like that, and let's
say this is five years,
and this is three years.
If you're building
a system and you've
budgeted for upgrading your
discs every four years,
then you're probably
better off using the thing
with the lower
value of mean time
to failure because its
expected lifetime is longer.
But if you're willing to
upgrade your discs every two
years or one year,
then you might
be better off with this thing
here with the lower meantime
to failure, even though its
expected operational lifetime
is smaller.
So both of these numbers
are actually meaningful,
and it depends a lot on how
you're planning to use it.
I mean, it's a lot like
spare tires on your car.
I mean, the spare tire
was run perfectly fine
as long as you don't
exceed 100 miles.
And the moment you
exceed 100 miles, then
you don't want to use it at all.
And it might be a lot cheaper
to build the spare tire
that runs just 100 miles
because the users, you
are guaranteed that you
will get to a repair shop
within 100 miles.
It's the same concept.
OK.
So one of the things
that we can define,
once we have this
condition of failure rate
is the reliability
of the system.
We'll define that as
the probability, R of T,
is the probability that
the system's working
at time T, given that it
was working at time zero,
or more generally assuming
that everything is always
working at time zero,
it's the probability
that you're OK at time T.
And it turns out that for
components in the flat region
of this curve, H of T, the
conditional failure rate is
a constant, on systems
that satisfy that,
and would satisfy the property
that the actual unconditional
failure rate is a [memory-less?]
process where the probability
of failure doesn't depend on how
long the system's been running.
It turns out that
for the systems that
satisfy those conditions,
which apparently discs
do in the operation
when they're actually
not at the right edge of
the curve, which discs do,
the reliability,
this function goes
as the very nice,
simple function, which
is an exponential decaying
function, E to the minus
T over MTTF.
And this is under
two conditions.
H of T has to be flat, and
the unconditional failure rate
has to be something that
doesn't depend on how
long the system's been running.
And for those systems,
it's not hard to show
that your reliability is
just an exponential decaying
function, which means you
can do a lot of things
like predict how long the
system is likely to be running,
and so on.
And that will tell you
when to upgrade things.
OK, so given all of
this stuff, we now
want techniques to cope with
failures, cope with faults.
And that's what we're
going to be looking
at for the next
few lectures, let's
take one simple example
of a system first.
And like I said before,
all of these systems
use redundancy in some form.
So the disk fails
at a certain rate.
Just put in multiple disks,
replicate the data across them,
and then hope that
things survive.
So the first kind of
redundancy that you
might have in the
example that I just
talked about, spatial
redundancy, where the idea is
that you have multiple
copies of the same thing,
and the games we're
going to play all
have to do with how we're going
to manage all these copies.
And actually, this will turn
out to be quite complicated.
We'll use these special copies
in a number of different ways.
In some examples, we'll
apply error correcting codes
to make copies of the data or
use other codes to replicate
the data.
We might replicate
data and make copies
of data in the form of
logs which keep track of,
you know, you run an operation.
You store some results.
But at the same time, before
you store those results,
you also store something
in a log [surf?],
the original data went away;
your log can tell you what
to do.
Or you might just do
plain and simple copies
followed by voting.
So the idea is that you have
multiple copies of something,
and then you write
to all of them.
In the simplest of schemes,
you might write to all of them,
and then when you want
to read something,
you read from all of them.
And then just what?
And go with the majority.
So intuitively that can tolerate
a certain number of failures.
And all of these
approaches have been used.
And people will continue
to build systems
along all of these ideas.
But in addition,
we're also going
to look at temporal redundancy.
And the idea here
is try it again.
So this is different
from copies.
What it says is
you try something.
If it doesn't work and you
determine that it doesn't work,
try it again.
So retry is an example
of temporal tricks.
But it will turn out will also
use not just moving forward
and retrying something that
we know should be retried,
we'll also use the
trick of undoing things
that we have done.
So we'll move both
directions on the time axis.
We'll retry stuff,
but at the same time
we'll also undo things because
sometimes things have happened
that shouldn't have happened.
Things went half way.
And we really want
to back things out.
And we were going to use
both of these techniques.
So one example of spatial
redundancy is a voting scheme.
And you can apply this to many
different kinds of systems.
But let's just apply it
to a simple example of,
there is data stored
in multiple occasions.
And then whenever
data is written,
it's written to all of them.
And then when you read it,
you read from all them,
and then you vote.
And in a simple model
where these components are
fail stop, which means that
they fail; they just fail.
Excuse me, on a simple
model where things are not
fail stop or fail fast, but just
report back this data to you,
so you are voting on it,
and these results come back.
You've written something in them
and when you read things back,
arbitrary values might get
returned if there's a failure.
And if there's no failure here,
correct values get returned.
Then as long as two of these
copies are correctly working,
or two of these versions
are correctly working,
then the vote will
actually return to you
at the correct output.
And that's the
idea behind voting.
So if the reliability of each
of these components is some R,
that's the probability that
the system's working at time T
according to that
definition of reliability.
Then, under the assumption
that these are completely
independent of each other,
which is a big assumption,
particularly for software.
But it might be a reasonable
assumption for something
like a disk, under the
assumption that these
are completely independent,
then you could write out
the reliability of this
three-voting scheme
of this thing where you are
voting on three outputs.
But you know that the
system is correctly
working if any two of these
are correctly working.
So that happens
under two conditions.
Firstly, all three are
correctly working, right?
Or, some two of the three
are correctly working.
And, there's three ways in
which you could choose some two
of the three.
And, one of them
is wrongly working.
And it turns out that
this number actually
is very, very large, much larger
than R, when R is close to one.
And, in general,
this is bigger than R
when each of the components
has high enough reliability,
namely, bigger than half.
And so, let's say that
each of these components
has a reliability of 95%.
If you work this number
out, it turns out
to be a pretty big number,
much higher than 95%,
much closer to one.
And, of course,
this kind of voting
is a bad idea if the
reliability of these components
is really low.
I mean, if it's below one
half, then chances are that
you're more likely the two
of them are just wrong,
and you agree on that result.
And it turns out to reduce
the reliability of the system.
Now, in general, you might think
that you can build systems out
of this basic voting idea,
and for various reasons
it turns out that this idea
has limited applicability
for the kinds of
things we want to do.
And a lot of that
stems from the fact
that these are not, in
general, in computer systems.
It's very hard to design
components that are completely
independent of each other.
It might work out OK for certain
hardware components where
you might do this
voting or other forms
of spatial redundancy
that gives you
these impressive
reliability numbers.
But for software, this
independent assumption
turns out to be
really hard to meet.
And there is an approach to
building software like this.
It's called N
version programming.
And it's still a
topic of research
where people are trying to build
software systems out of voting.
But you have to pay a lot of
attention and care to make sure
that these software
components that
are doing the same function
are actually independent,
maybe written by
different people running
on different operating
systems, and so on.
And that turns out to be a
pretty expensive undertaking.
It's still sometimes
necessary if you
want to build something
highly reliable.
But because of its
cost it's not something
that is the sort of
cookie-cutter technique
for achieving highly
reliable software systems.
And so what we're going to
see starting for next time
is a somewhat different
approach for achieving
software reliability that
doesn't rely on voting, which
won't actually achieve the
same degree of reliability
as these kinds of
systems, but will achieve
a different kind of
reliability that we'll talk
about starting from next time.